the Senate Intelligence Committee is
preparing for a highly anticipated
hearing this week with former FBI
director James Comey Comey is scheduled
to testify Thursday about his
conversations with President Trump
Intelligence Committee members mark
Warner and Susan Collins spoke with John
Dickerson on Face the Nation yesterday
about the questions they want answered I
want to know what kind of pressure
appropriate inappropriate how many
conversations he had with the president
about this topic did some of these
conversations take place even before the
president was sworn in this will give us
a chance to get his perspective on the
issue of Russian involvement and also on
the issue of collaboration or collusion
what is he seeing what initial judgments
has he made Democratic Senator Joe
Manchin of West Virginia is also on the
Intelligence Committee good morning the
morning or what's the big question that
you have for the FBI director the
question has been asked by West
Virginians is if you knew or if you
thought there was obstruction of justice
why didn't you act on it and what should
the FBI director well we're anxious to
hear this if how in-depth or what he
thought he was suspicious did he came
back after that meeting and he took all
his notes and filed everything properly
what was his concerns and if there was
deeper concerns why wasn't nothing
Senate done in time yeah you're talking
about what happened on Valentine's Day
inside the Oval Office there's the
Attorney General the Vice President
United States and the FBI director the
president Eights asked the Attorney
General and the vice president to leave
and then reportedly says to the FBI
director I hope you can let this go
meaning the whole Russia investigation
does that raise questions what does
raise questions we want to find out what
Comey was thinking at that time if he
thought it was had risen to that level
of obstruction and if it had why hadn't
something been done why didn't he act on
he was - FBI director if not was that
concern basically filed away for what
purpose his director Comey gonna be in
either by himself or by others on any
restrictions as to what he can say no he
will not go above an open source
basically what you're saying or what's
been reported in the public he's not
going as I understand into a classified
Intel will
sometimes an open meeting such as what
you'll see Thursday and then we go into
another classified setting which is
pretty secure is the president trying to
get executive privilege for him and if
he is will it be successful I don't
think so we have not heard that
whatsoever hasn't been brought to the
committee as far as I know the were
there asking for that I know it's been
reported that that might be done if he
tried that what would be your answer I
think it'd be wrong absolutely I want to
go back to the memos that you said your
constituents raise because we know that
you took very copious notes have you or
anybody on the committee seen the memos
and how important are they to this to
this this hearing on Thursday I haven't
seen those memos yet you want to see
them yes we do we want to see all the
memos I will say this our intelligent
committee is made up of 17 of I think of
truly Americans not Democrats
Republicans and Americans they're going
to make decisions based on the Intel
we've been told and we always believe
that the Intel takes you where the for
the facts the facts will take you to the
truth then you make your decision I
don't think any one person whether it's
a homeless person or a person to highest
level of government such as the
president is going to be spared if
something is wrong that's the rule of
law Senator Mark Warner said there's a
lot of smoke but he's seen no smoking
gun is that your position true did you
mom always say if there's a lot of smoke
there must be fire yeah this is it yes
is there ever seen coming there saying a
lot of smoke signals yeah there's a with
that there's a lot of people that we
know were involved in had had some sort
of contact relationships with the
Russians I just you know the Russians
are not our ally they're not in this to
make it a better America they want
people to distrust distrust their
government not to have confidence that's
what their intentions are through their
news media through all the propaganda
everything they do we should get to the
bottom of it Center listen Vladimir
Putin did an interview over the weekend
with another Network said listen this is
nonsense this is foolishness or
something along those lines you all are
really just making all of this up it
didn't happen the way you're saying do
you think we'll really ever get to the
bottom of this well the Intel is very
very pointed in the direct that they
have gotten more involved they became
more involved and they did everything to
become more involved than ever before
but we've been doing and going back in
this raid for the last 30 40 50 years
why do you think the president
refuses to acknowledge that that I
cannot answer that could be the $64,000
question we have to find out I want to
make sure this gets behind us and I've
said this where the b2 Michael Flynn who
we knew when I was on Armed Services
help us prove your innocence
don't make us pull out you're guilty the
president has an agenda it has to do
with health care it has to do with
immigration it has to do with facts
reform it has to do with infrastructure
all of that is he going to get any of
that pass before the 2018 election I
would sure hope so because this country
needs it counts on all of us to act as
Americans what's best for our country
the Democrats Republicans have become so
siloed that if you have a D by your
neighbor and are by your name you're on
the other side you're the enemy I don't
think that's the oath we all take and we
all take the same oath so why can't we
get together and find out how can we
have a tax reform that really works
gets rid of $23 of debt starts paying
that debt down and secures the country
what did you tell the president about
health care in West Virginia I told the
president I said mr. president there's
180 thousand plus West Virginians that
received health care for the first time
under the first time under the
Affordable Care Act they don't know how
they got it they don't know it was a
Democrat initiative they voted
overwhelmingly for you mr. president
they don't know how they got it they
know how they're going to lose and they
know who took it away from be very
careful where you're going don't use the
word repeal what was his response to
that he listened he listened and we're
hoping that he'll work on that and act
with us but you can't repeal something
that basically we're agreeing 50%
pre-existing conditions caps senior
doughnut hole being filled children
keeping 20 we believe on so many things
why would you throw that out and try to
start over we can't get 60 votes but it
looks like a conflict away out of time
it looks like a contact do you believe
yes or no that conflict can be solved
before the 2018 election I believe it
has to be solved charlie if it doesn't
god help America because we can't
continue down this road and you can't go
back to what we have which is nothing
Thank You senator Manchin always good to
have you thank you no it's good to be
with you